nobody expected us to be a simple
slasher film on the surface it's a movie
about evil doppelgangers and all the
horror scenarios you can dream up with
that kind of premise Plus scissors
scissors suck but now that it's here
it's clear that there are multiple
layers that might get lost in a casual
viewing so let's dig into all the small
details that had to offer get ready
because we're untethering the mysteries
behind us spoilers ahead if you were
paying attention you might have noticed
that the entire plot of us was spelled
out in the opening seconds of the film
after that long title shot with the
rabbits us opens on a TV playing a
commercial for the Hands Across America
movement on either side of the TV our
VHS tapes which included the man with
two brains The Goonies and chud it turns
out that when you put those all together
you have the movie us in the man with
two brains Steve Martin stars as a brain
surgeon who telepathically connects with
a disembodied brain in a jar like in us
it deals with a mental connection
between two physical forms ladies and
gentlemen I can envision a day when the
brains of brilliant men can be kept
alive in the bodies of dumb people in
The Goonies of course the kid's
adventure leads them underground
just like Adelaide when she follows her
doppelganger into the tunnels below the
surface one of the lines that read says
in the climax of the film actually comes
directly from The Goonies
she says it's our time it's our time up
there which echoes one of my keys most
famous phrases down here it's our time
finally chud or cannibalistic humanoid
underground dwellers deals with mutants
living in the sewers under New York City
who begin attacking people on the
surface the parallels there probably
don't need much explanation so what was
up with all that hand-holding the
tethers were in - in the climax Rhett
explained a bit of it but if you weren't
around in the 80s you might not be
familiar with the crazy charity stunt
that the Washington Post has lovingly
dubbed the most 80s thing to happen in
the 80s the charity stunt was Hands
Across America a 1986 event that tried
to raise money for the homeless by
having people stand hand in hand across
the entire United States the premise was
that we're all the same and we're all
connected so why not pay $10 to make a
countrywide umbilical with all your
peers
connect it see you guys it's Hands
Across America so we were just saying we
almost made it couple breaks in the
chain right heads across America Pele
has explained in interviews that his
vision for the script was heavily
influenced by that moment and it
definitely shows in us one of the
earliest scenes in the film is that
commercial after that the references pop
up everywhere young Adelaide is wearing
a Hands Across America shirt under her
thriller shirt when she's abducted the
evil red uses the movement to organize
her tethered of abelian and at the end
all the tethered form a similar link
across Santa Cruz maybe even the whole
country for all we know in the original
charity event it was for the homeless in
us it's for the weird psychic
underground clones but the message is
the same we won't be forgotten anymore
in keeping with the partial 80s setting
of us there's one Easter Egg that almost
definitely slipped past anyone who isn't
a die-hard fan of the quintessentially
80s teen vampire flake The Lost Boys and
let's be honest so that's pretty much
everyone right both movies use the Santa
Cruz Boardwalk as a filming location but
while The Lost Boys changed the town's
name us was open about the film's
setting so open in fact that during the
scenes taking place in 1986
he'd alluded to a real life event that
happened there the filming of the lost
voice wild young Adelaide is walking
with her parents her mom tells her dad
something along the lines of they're
filming a movie over by the carousel
he'll confirmed in an interview that the
line indeed referenced the Lost Boys and
most likely the scene of Kiefer
Sutherland on a carousel the only way to
hit that nail harder on the head would
have been to have young Adelaide walk
past the sexy jazz man Oh what could
have been
you definitely noticed the scissors
those golden implements of stabbing us
were everywhere in us in hands and
bellies and that one guy's crotch in
everything and there's no doubt that
scissors are scary horror weapons
they're sharp they're in practically
every home in the world
and they're an integral part of the
scariest jump scene ever filmed that's
pretty scary right because scissors are
scary but in the pee lovers as usual
there's a dual meaning to those golden
scissors like the cutout paper people
the shadows as the family walks across
the beach for the
first time and the house of mirrors the
scissors and us are both separate and
the same simultaneously feel himself
explained it best when talking about the
imagery he wanted to create with the
scissors saying the inherent duality of
to equal objects that are connected and
an object that's used to sever or cut is
very important to the film no way maybe
Tim Heidegger explained it best every
star has a sister star a little bit like
two eyeballs if you can imagine if you
could see the other side of my eyeball
you'd see a 360-degree eyeball there are
a lot of themes running through us one
of which is the horror centric idea of
creatures from the deep coming up to
prey on surface dwellers and the biggest
nod to that came in the form of Jason's
jaw shirt there's clearly a lot of Jaws
influence on us aside from the idea of
predators lurking beneath us the scenes
on the beach are also reminiscent of
Steven Spielberg's classic shark
thriller even one of the specific
sequences when Adelaide realizes that
Jason is missing and suddenly sees all
the innocent Beach fun in a series of
sharp staccato sinister moments was
pieced together a lot like the scene in
Jaws in which chief rody is on the
lookout for a shark before the big
attack in an interview with Rolling
Stone Peale revealed some of the
inspiration behind his latest film and
it comes from an understandable place
The Twilight Zone
one of TV's oldest and best benchmarks
for horror in particular Pele pulled
inspiration from a 1960 episode titled
mirror-image want to guess what it's
about yep evil doppelgangers in the
episode a woman at a bus station on a
rainy night sees another person who
looks exactly like her as time goes on
she gets more and more agitated about it
until she's carted off by the police at
which point it's revealed that she
wasn't crazy after all the other woman
was actually a mirror image from another
dimension counterpart
after the 2 Worlds converged comes into
our world and in order to survive it has
to take over
the obvious connection is there in us by
making the antagonist mirror images of
the main characters but peel no doubt
gave this an extra visual when he put
Adelaide's first meeting with her tether
in a literal house of mirrors with a
conveniently placed sign that says find
yourself at the front door check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movie details are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]